today's topic the new zealand
weightlifter laurel hubbard is set to
become
the first transgender athlete to compete
at the olympics
the country's olympic committee has
named her as part of the women's team
for the tokyo games
i asked our correspondent phil mercer
about the background to this decision
sport is all about pushing boundaries
and that's certainly what laurel hubbard
will be doing
at the tokyo olympics she will be the
first
transgender athlete to compete at the
game she has satisfied domestic
and international criteria she was
competing
in men's events until she transitioned
in 2012 and
she's had a pretty decorated career for
new zealand
back in 2017 she won a silver medal
at the world championships she thought
her career was over
at the commonwealth games a year later
in 2018 when she broke her arm
but she's back to full fitness and back
in the squad
and new zealand olympic officials are
very
cognizant of the fact that uh gender
identity in their words
is a very sensitive and complex issue in
sport
that requires a balance between human
rights
and the need for fairness in the field
of play there will be those who
disapprove
of her selection but as far as the
athlete herself
is concerned she said in a statement
that she was humbled and that she was
grateful
you know who's not grateful
the person who got booted off the team
to make place for her
yeah she's really not happy about the
fact that she's been made a replacement
yes i mean it has caused a little bit of
controversy hasn't it
certainly has uh sport is uh about drama
and certainly the inclusion of laurel
hubbard in new zealand's olympic squad
will add an extra layer of intrigue
now for quite a long time now there's
been a heated debate in sporting in
scientific
circles about uh an apparent unfairness
or an apparent advantage
gained by transgender athletes competing
against
other women and safe to say this
controversy will almost certainly
continue there have been rumblings of
discontent
among at least one of her weightlifting
rivals in the past
and you'd have to say due to the
sensitive and delicate nature of
it of this particular issue it will
continue
first off i appreciate the report it's
good it was balanced it was uh straight
to the point gave all the facts and
well done now we've already covered
laura harbert in the past
she was one of those people who i
mentioned do you remember when i did the
other trans video
i said you know what if it's so
equitable and so fair why is it that we
only hear
about trans women breaking records but
never about trans men
and i made a whole list where i showed
the greatest athletes
that were posted by trains websites
right they had the trans man trans women
the trans men never accomplished
anything of snoke the trans women broke
went out to break records
and were absolutely prolific at what
they did so
she was one of those people that i
mentioned she'd won medals before
now look what i'm gonna say i'm gonna
keep it very brief
the science on this while not a hundred
percent conclusive it's still pretty
clear
that despite the ioc's needs
from these trans folks to be able to
compete
there's still a physical advantage that
they gain from the fact that they were
they are male
right and so when you compete in this
field as a male
even though you've gone through whatever
it is the hormone therapy all this stuff
those advantages don't completely
disappear a lot of them still stay there
and so
in the sport in the olympics where the
margin for error is often a few
milliseconds
even less at times those kind of
advantages make all the difference and
i think this is grossly unfair the
people who will get replaced think this
is unfair
and going to the olympics is a big deal
the kind of endorsements that you get
the experience the pinnacle of your
sport
to have your spot taken because a trans
athlete who has an unfair advantage gets
to take that spot
it's not right so those are my thoughts
i'm all for it there's no backing down
there's no
having a different way of having stuff
it's happening
it's it's happening there's nothing we
could do about it
women's sport is not what it used to be
or what it's never going to be used
it's going to be what it is now now
trans women can compete against women
that's it
let's embrace it it doesn't matter if
it's fair or not it doesn't matter if
it's
dangerous or not none of that matters it
doesn't
fairness nah it doesn't matter they get
to compete and that's okay
and we're gonna make them feel better
and we're gonna welcome them in their
sports
we're gonna have to say goodbye to women
competing and breaking records
but at the end of the day it's okay
let's welcome them into sports there's
nothing we could do
to stop that let's embrace it it's
happening
we're at the olympics it's happening now
they can't have a couple of
of states that are canceling trans teens
to but when you're gonna be at the
olympics it's gonna happen
at the level of the olympics that's
gonna happen you're gonna be able to do
that
so it's just
really weird that an organization that
wants to ban things that are
unfair like you know um hyperbaric
chambers
steroids and stuff like that you are
ready you're ready to pass
over that kind of this disadvantage if
we want to do that
let's be open with all with everything
put the chambers but the stairs put
everything
let's just do all of that why not since
that
advantage doesn't matter let's just
let's just let's go
let's just go we're going all in we're
going in
we're in we're already in let's go all
in
give me the steroids give me the
chambers
give me all of that things that you
don't want us to to
to use go ahead let's do it let's do
that
you're claiming steroids are not safe
for people
and now you're doing this cool give me
the steroids i want everything
i want everything i want everything now
i want everything
you disprove your point right there
which is fine that's okay
but let's be let's be logical with that
let's go i'm embracing trans women
competing with women i embrace that
let's go
give me everything all right there's a
period where russians were dominating
the olympics
taking gold silver and then years later
found out they were all cheating and
what ended up happening
is that all the people who came in third
fourth fifth were promoted the first
they were awarded gold medals
problem is it happened two three years
afterwards why is this important
because the impact on the olympians was
tremendous
they didn't get to have any of the press
that would help them out with their
career they didn't get any of the
endorsements they didn't get any
financials they just have their name in
a record book in the medal but they're
not
recognized when you put people in these
unfair competitions you rob them
of their chance at excellence that's
what it comes down to
the reason why women don't compete with
men there's a clear unfair advantage
women would never be in any race or any
competition
this is the truth if they have to
compete against males so you having a
man who
male who transitions it's not fair
and if this opens the flood game there's
a whole bunch of trans athletes who come
afterwards and they start competing
you're going to see it's only going to
get worse
science is also behind this idea so
that's why i'm just
i'm just we covered this in the past you
know two years ago or whatever
we'll cover it again today because it's
absolutely ridiculous i hope they fix
this issue
hope they fix this issue because i know
why he's saying abrasive because he
wants to troll
what i'm telling you i'm not even trying
there's no going back
there is going back you can undo stuff
that's that's ridiculous but that's not
the direction that they're going i'm not
even
you can turn around just because you're
one direction doesn't mean you can't
change
either so to me that's a troll but in
the meantime there's people who are
going to suffer
those people are going to lose out on
opportunities because of this so
you know just i hope people are more
mindful that it's like you're you're
completely changing people's lives
yeah if you might have to compete with
women you would never have serena
williams
you would never have naomi socks you
never have any tennis stars
and that's not our opinion that's what
she says that's what she said so i'm
just like think about the implications
of this and the female athletes they
don't want it either
so no they don't no that's all my
thoughts on it i think it's unfortunate
i think this is a gross misconduct
and it's just like i just can't stand
all the wokeness everything is just
everything is always about being
politically correct even people willing
to throw
science aside to do that
[Music]
is
no time for fake ones
that keeps you